comment défendre son image quand on est
situé dans la périphérie parisienne
bon nombre de villes sont directement
confrontés au problème certaines ont
décidé de relever le défi et elles sont
en passe de gagner
c'est le cas de suresnes qui affiche
clairement son slogan être bien dans sa
ville c'est être bien également dans sa
vie illustration dans ce reportage de
philippe gassot et franck brice est pas
facile d'éviter l'étouffement quand on
est une commune de la banlieue proche de
paris
c'est sans doute ce qui explique la
multiplication des fêtes locales
depuis longtemps les livres d'histoire
ont été examinés à la noue afin d'y
découvrir l'éventuel passage d'une reine
ou d'un roi c'est bon pour les racines
tout ceci participe à la conquête d'une
identité mais cela n'est pas suffisant
pour sonner la mobilisation générale
il faut faire plus car suresnes veut
jouer les premiers rôles la figuration
et les rôles d' hallebardiers on
consomme avec modération se sentir bien
dans sa ville c'est être bien dans sa
vie
vous faites comme ça permet en fait à
l'ensemble de la population que ce soit
les jeunes que ce soit les adultes c'est
soit les personnes âgées de je dirais de
vivre autrement leur ville et d'horreur
en fait de se rencontrer de se
reconnaître et de s'accepter avec leurs
différences la fête est donc une chose
très sérieuse
c'est la partie immergée d'une action
menée en profondeur et qui rend possible
la vie en commun c'est une manière de
permettre aux sur et noix des différents
quartiers des différents immeubles des
différentes catégories de se retrouver
avec ce point commun et découvrir que
finalement leur appartenance à une
communauté plus important que tout ce
qui les différencie les uns les autres
ça les enfants le savent bien ton pays
d'origine
quel est votre ville vous répondez quoi
être du même endroit s'y sentir bien
c'est en fait se ressemblent voilà je
connaissais le piccolo d'argenteuil mais
pas le petit